Set against the tumultuous
backdrop of the 1967 Newark Riots,
"The Many Saints of Newark" is a prequel to "The
Sopranos," HBO's smash hit prestige TV series
that became a cultural phenomenon when it debuted
back in 1999. The film is co-written by David
Chase, who created the original "Sopranos"
series and its colorful cast of characters.
Starring James Gandolfini's son Michael Gandolfini
as young Tony Soprano, "The Many Saints of Newark"
chronicles the formative years of Tony as
a kid and a teenager, and the impactful
relationship he shared with his mob boss uncle
Dickie Moltisanti. As fans well know, it would
not exactly be a spoiler to say that young Tony
grows up to follow in Uncle Dickie's footsteps.
So how does this improbable prequel end?
Does the ending serve as a logical prologue
to "The Sopranos"? Or is it telling its own
story, simply set in David Chase's universe?
The opening shot gently pans
over a gloomy graveyard,
getting closer and closer to what is
revealed to be Christopher's grave -- yes,
that Christopher. In the first few
shots of the movie, the audience
hears the voice of Christopher Moltisanti,
telling the story from beyond the grave.
Since Christopher is a baby in the time period
that "Many Saints" takes place, he hardly factors
into the prequel story. Tony exclaims that his
baby nephew only ever cries when he is around,
pretty deftly foreshadowing their
tumultuous future relationship,
which takes a murderous turn during
the timeline of "The Sopranos."
"Some babies, when they come into the world,
know all kinds of things from the other side."
These little referential treats aside, the
story of "Many Saints" doesn't really turn out
to be about Tony or Christopher by the end. It's
got a lot more to do with the man whose shadow
extends over their relationship for decades to
come: Christopher's father, Dickie Moltisanti.
While the movie is mostly framed
through young Tony's point of
view as he experiences the chaos and
violence surrounding him and his family,
the story is really more focused on the trials
and tribulations of Dickie Moltisanti's life.
In an interview with The Hollywood
Reporter, director Alan Taylor said,
"It was important to feel [Tony] powerfully
in the movie even though
structurally it's Dickie's story."
This certainly seems to suggest that the focus
on Dickie is just as the creators intended.
This is part of the reason Christopher narrates
instead of our present-day POV character, young
Tony. Tony's environment and his pivotal bond with
Dickie essentially morphs him into the New Jersey
mob boss that he infamously becomes, but "Many
Saints" isn't really a Tony Soprano origin story.
At the crux of the film are the tensions
between the white and Black residents of
Newark, New Jersey after a Black man is
killed by the Newark police, a real life
incident that resulted in uprisings
that nearly burned the city down.
The generational conflict between the mob and
the Black community is a constant presence in
"Many Saints," with the heightened racial
tensions serving as more setting than plot
point. This ambient tension is made manifest in
the story via the looming conflict between Dickie
and a Black man named Harold McBrayer
with whom he used to do business.
When McBrayer turns against Dickie for killing one
of his own, an all out war ensues between the two
rival factions of Newark. It becomes a blood bath
between the Italian mob and McBrayer and his crew.
If racial and cultural tensions were always
simmering beneath the surface on "The Sopranos,"
they claim top billing in
the plot of "Many Saints."
Even though the film is a period piece, this
choice makes it feel current and culturally
relevant, and may even provide a fresh lens
through which to revisit "The Sopranos."
Interestingly, the film's culminating act
of violence isn't an act of racial animus,
but rather a manifestation of the
conflicts within the Italian mob.
This dynamic, too, will be familiar to fans
of "The Sopranos" -- no matter how many
threats attack from the outside, it's always the
threats from within that prove the most deadly.
Toward the end of the film, in a surprise twist,
Dickie is suddenly shot and killed by someone who
is revealed to have been hired by Junior Soprano,
Tony's uncle and a member of the family who has
always been at odds with Dickie. Earlier, Dickie
even humiliates Junior in a very public way by
laughing at him when he falls down the
stairs at Dickie's father's funeral.
It's interesting to consider the ways
this struggle between Junior and Dickie
replays a generation later between Junior and
Tony — Junior tries to kill Tony in Season 1,
you'll recall — and how this twist
reveals the truth about Barry Haydu,
the retired cop who Christoper thinks killed
his father, because Tony convinced him of
this … and who Christopher murders
in his home at the start of Season 4.
"You're being set up! He's
lying to you, whoever he is!"
At Dickie's funeral, Tony stands staring
at Dickie in the open casket. He imagines
himself making a pinky swear with Dickie. It's
a callback to a moment earlier in the film,
but more importantly, it foreshadows the
way Tony will continue Dickie's legacy.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite new movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.